Pour 1 développement durable,
l'Afrique et l'Europe doivent
travailler ensemble dans 1
esprit d'ouverture
et de complémentarité.
C'est la conviction du chef de l'état,
le président Macky Sall,
lancé, selon dit les travaux de la conférence
réunion opaque deux-mille-vingt-trois.
Réuni à Dakar, l'alliance des libéraux et démocrates
a exprimé sa reconnaissance
au président Macky Sall pour la promotion
des valeurs de cette idéologie ou marking
pour les libéreuses et démocrates.
Le rendez-vous de Dakar est d'abord en hommage appuyé
à 1 leader qui a beaucoup fait pour le Sénégal
et l'Afrique.
Je voudrais, si vous permettez, monsieur le président,
vous exprimer ma gratitude.
J'ai été effectivement élu
en terre de territanga
et je n'oublierai jamais ce jour-là,
monsieur le président.
C'était lors de votre investiture.
Vous m'avez fait l'honneur de prendre la parole
pour la 1ère fois.
C'était ma 1ère
devant des milliers,
des milliers de personnes
où on sentait 1 reconnaissance de vous lire
votre leadership,
mais on sentait
l'amour que vous avez impulsé
dans les cœurs des Sénégalais.
Monsieur le président,
j'ai vu évoluer le Sénégal,
je l'ai vu depuis ce jour où j'ai eu
cette joie de participer à cette réinte
grande réunion
et j'ai vu
le chemin parcouru au niveau de l'infrastructure,
au niveau de la vision.
J'ai vu votre combat en temps
que l'idéal national pour l'éducation,
pour les droits des femmes, pour les jeunes
et d'ailleurs on va en parler tout à l'heure.
Et j'ai vu aussi
votre combat au niveau de l'international.
Vous. Êtes la parole qui incarne la voix des Africains.
Alors en tant que présidente de l'international libéral,
je ne peux que vous demander d'applaudir,
monsieur le président.
Vous prenez nos valeurs.
Dakar est 1 choix loin d'être gratuit
pour ce que le libéralisme représente avec 1 précurseur
connu et reconnu,
c'est l'occasion pour moi, avant d'entamer
mon allocution,
de rendre hommage au père de l'libéralisme africain
et sénégalais,
maître de la wad,
qui nous a inspirés
écology était plutôt 1 idéologie,
marciste lenémis
et du socialisme ancien
qui faisait rage dans sur le continent africain.
Il a osé emprunter la voie du libéralisme.
Donc, tout ce que vous voyez dans cette rangée,
ainsi que moi-même,
nous sommes des héritiers
de ce libéralisme
inspiré par Abdoulaye wod que je salue.
Afrique Europe,
comment favoriser le développement durable,
le thème est au cœur des échanges du sommeil de Dakar.
Pour le président Macky Sall,
les 2 continents ont toutes les raisons de s'unir,
entre l'Europe et l'Afrique,
il y a 1 longue histoire,
longue histoire avec ses présenteurs
et 1 proximité géographique étroite
puisque seulement 15km
nous sépare
entre l'Europe et l'Afrique. Il y a le coût immense
de la guerre.
Payez ensemble 2 fois en l'espace d'une génération,
dans la souffrance,
dans le sang et dans les larmes.
Il y a 1 coopération ancienne
et multiforme.
Il y a enfin 1 brassage humain
de longue date
qui a fécondé de multiples affinités sociaux,
culturelles et linguistiques.
Tout nous condamne au dialogue.
À la concertation
et d'une certaine façon,
à vivre ensemble
dans le respect de nos diversités,
voire de nos différences.
L'Afrique et l'Europe ont donc toutes les raisons
de travailler ensemble
dans 1 esprit d'ouverture et de compréhension.
À mon sens, il faut, de portée d'hôte,
prendre conscience de toutes ces mutations
comme marqueur du présent
et du futur et sur cette base,
refondé,
repenser et revitaliser
nos relations.
1 langage informatique. Si je peux emprunter ce langage,
je dirais plus qu'une mise à jour,
nous avons besoin d'un nouveau logiciel
pour ajouter à nos vieux paramètres
les nouvelles données de notre temps.
Dans ce Nouveau Monde qui se dessine,
on a souvent besoin d'un plus petit que soi,
comme le lion
et le rat dans la fameuse fable de la fontaine.
Ensemble, nous devons combattre le terrorisme
en Afrique
parce que nos proximités et nos intérêts,
comment font que ?
Car l'Afrique tousse,
l'Europe éternue
et vice-versa.
Ensemble,
il nous faut bâtir des partenariats consensuels,
rénovés
et mutuellement bénéfiques.
C'est pourquoi j'ai salué l'initiative,
cette loi sur les minéraux critiques.
Il faut que ces minéraux soient transformés
sur le continent
pour créer la valeur ajoutée et les emplois.
Il nous faut
donc des partenariats qu'on construit
sur les fondements de priorité
et valeurs partagées.
Ensemble, nous devons également
agir sur le plan économique
pour l'assouplissement des règles de lecider
afin de mieux faciliter
l'accès des pays en développement
africain, en particulier
au crédit export,
a des conditions de maturité plus longue.
Et de taux d'intérêt plus soutenables,
et ceci pour renforcer l'investissement et le commerce
entre les 2 continents.